how do I maintain being a husband that
is present with my wife while also
consistently grinding to achieve my
goals you don't Welcome to our special
end of year Q&A couples Edition you guys
have questions and we may or may not
have good answers to them enjoy what do
you do for dates expensive restaurants
chill at home Etc I think we go to
expensive restaurants sometimes and
sometimes we chill at home and just like
watch movies and do nothing I will say
that our need for dates is proportionate
for how much we're working so if we are
working a lot we will need to take dates
if we are not working a 10 we kind of
have enough time with one another
intermittently that I feel like our need
for like carving out time goes down a
lot for me I delineate date night versus
going out to eat because for context we
go out to eat pretty much every night of
the week and so what makes it special if
you go out all the time like is it the
fanciness of the restaurant not really
because we do a lot of business dinners
and things like that and so we go out to
like five star restaurants probably
three nights a week we go to Jimmy
John's more nights well now we go to
Jimmy John's too Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A
Chipotle Chipotle we don't Chipotle plac
wish chipot it would be nice
oh my God anyways anyway stomach let's
not get into that my point was that the
difference between going out for a
business dinner and going out on a date
is that I dress up and by dress up it
means I don't wear
this and so that's the yeah I shower I
put deodorant on and I don't wear a hat
we go incognito mode yeah no one can
recognize me that's actually in my
opinion the the main delineation between
going out to eat for work or whatever
versus when we go out and actually like
do a date that's the main difference if
we do a at home version of that it's
like we're going to watch a movie
together that we both feel like watching
like Twilight like
Twilight I'm Team Jacob we were both
Team Jacob Cameron is the next question
oh I wasn't going in order oh you're
just picking got it okay picking the she
like it's like ice cream at home she'll
pick out all the chunks all the good
ones and then she'll just leave me like
vanilla I feel like when we have like 17
pins of ice cream that's acceptable I
feel like it's never I just buy another
pint you don't you just leave it like a
like a used corpse that just got like
all of its organs taken out of it it's
true how do I maintain being a husband
that is present with my wife while also
consistently grinding to achieve my
goals easy you don't you just sacrifice
yourself as a husband so you can achieve
your goals to give an actual realistic
answer to the husband who asked that
question no one works effectively 24
hours a day it's about doing effective
work not just sitting in front of the
computer pretending to be productive and
I say pretending not that this person is
but like I would be pretending to be
productive Pro productively
procrastinating like if you know that
your work output drops prit of time and
I usually know what type of work I'm
doing so for me I'm editing I know how
many paragraphs I can edit per unit of
time or how many pages I can type or how
many slides I can make in a presentation
so if you have work that you are
comfortable knowing what your rate of
progress is if I start seeing that drop
a lot I usually call it because then my
quality of work also go down cu the next
then I have to fix all the stuff anyways
so the tldr is when your output goes
down sub that with a higher Roi thing so
it's like if I have 16 hours of awake
time per day if I do 15 hours of work
and 1 hour of marriage time I'll get a
really high Roi on that first hour of of
marriage time and so like optimizing
around life is like the ROI I get from
that 1 hour is worth dropping the last
hour of work and so I think I try and
think about it like that is like what's
my minimum effective dose um for each
goal and usually you can still heavily
index on achieving your goals because it
usually takes more time than your
marriage does and then have the time
when you do need to rest and recharge to
be dedicated to your spouse and I think
it's also like Seasons you know like
when you're writing a book I think in
the very beginning when you did the
first bout where I realized like oh
we're not going to have a lot of time
with each other it took me a minute to
like accept that we but all are going to
go through Seasons like that in our
lives and the bigger your goals are one
I think the more understanding you need
to be as a partner for that person
because the bigger the vision they have
for their lives the more that you're
going to have to recognize that that
requires sacrifice and bouts you having
those big goals for yourself was the
first time in a relationship that I had
a man who had bigger goals for himself
than I even had for myself which I was
grateful for and I'm grateful because I
felt like the relationship at many times
I had in the past was just distracting
from my goals whereas it should Propel
you faster to your goals because you
support each other in a way that creates
an environment where it's easier for
each of you to hit your goals than
harder and I think a lot of people make
it harder for their spouse to hit their
goals than easier there's always going
to be times where we're going to give
each other leftovers and it is what it
is but I think what we're really good at
doing is we communicate about it and it
remains an open dialogue versus like
complaining to other people or being
passive aggressive like it doesn't turn
into that ever and I think a lot of
spouses have unrealistic goals for one
another and what they what that means
for me is that like you have to accept
the tradeoff for the thing that you want
most and so if you want a spouse who's
super goal oriented and super ambitious
the trade-off the price tag for that is
that they're going to work more and
their schedule's not going to be as
flexible they're not going to be able to
go drop of a hat get away you know
weekends and vacations and stuff if
that's the season they're in and so I
just think it's unfair of either spouse
to have dual desires of things that
conflict and so you just have to in my
opinion pick the one that matters more
to you I think we have just changed our
expectations over time so that they
actually meet reality and so if this
individual is upset or feels like
expectations what he quote should be
doing as a husband or is not what he's
currently doing he either needs to
change the expectations of what he needs
to do to be a good husband or he needs
to accept that this is actually the new
new normal for whatever season he's in
next question this one's for you was
there ever a time where you felt you
shouldn't or couldn't be working
together I think the only only time that
I ever even questioned us working
together was the one fight we got into
basically we had a large disagreement on
where to take the business and what
decision to make with our software
business I think we like locked
ourselves in a room for like 2 days
because we realized we completely
disagreed Alex steamrolled me and I let
him but I in a way realized from that
experience that I allowed him to take
full responsibility for the outcome by
not using better skills of influence to
try and get him to see my point instead
I was just very frustrated I gave up and
I was like screw it whatever we'll do it
your way what I don't have to do at that
point is take responsibility for an
outcome every time that you you kind of
do that in a conversation what it really
was doing was like this is a really
scary decision and now I'll just let
Alex take responsibility for the outcome
one of the things that Lea's improved a
lot on is um I used to be like sell me
on it like I want to believe you but I'm
not sold like sell me on it she would
just say like this is what we need to do
even though there was like a mountain of
a hundred things behind it she would
just say the end of the problem of the
math problem but it was like show your
work I don't get how you went from here
to here and I just I didn't see the dots
connecting people see us now and they're
like you guys have a really good
partnership but I mean it took years of
work oh my God and communication it was
really hard in the for the first few
years yeah we've only had one real big
argument in our careers and it was about
business it was even about like
relationship stuff do you train or do
Fitness Together if not why not I don't
think I'm a good training
partner historically I don't train well
with many people like I like having a
trainer to yell at me you also don't
like that trainer who's yelling at you
to be your spouse
correct and that's how Alex trains
people so instead of him yelling at me
and me doing the exercise I just go why
are you yelling at me stop yelling at me
actually I think now if we train
together it would be completely
different to be fair I actually just
like going to the gym listening to music
and not talking to anybody yeah so we go
to the gym at the same time and we don't
work out together it work worked fine we
love the car ride there and the car ride
back Yeah we actually yeah we we enjoy
the car ride when did you know she was
the one that was fit for you as your
spouse and her the same to you I was
waiting for you to say how' you know I
was the one you looked at me creepily
and I was like that's that's how I knew
she looked at me like I was gets me
going like a piece of meat no I mean I
had I had a handful of moments big
moment number one was when you went to
Hawaii and Soldier ass off when we
weren't together so we we split for like
30 days so she could do a launch I just
had a head-on collision DUI my mother
was in the hospital I just split with
two different business partners in the
last 30 days I just lost all my money
like it was it was all all of this
happened in like a 60-day period
honestly it was just cuz she stood tall
when everything else was crumbling
around me and I didn't I didn't deserve
the Loyalty that she chose to show me
you stood tall and like basically
followed through with my commitments
even though you didn't owe me anything
cuz I basically made the agreement to
the gym own that we'd launch it but like
we broke up she could have just left and
gone home like that she could have done
that and she didn't when I lost
everything the second
time uh Lila was like I would sleep with
you under a bridge if it came to that I
was like I like you but like I respect
that if you don't find me respectable at
this moment cuz I have nothing she was
like I'm in and so that was I mean
honestly those are probably two big
moments for me yeah we had all the heart
in the beginning of our relationship
like all the hard stuff was before we
got married what about you um never
asked that yeah what were your moments
one of them was after you got the DUI
and real winner no I mean and then I was
like what's he going to do next you just
completely turn [__] around when you see
someone there in like their darkest
moments like what are they going to do
and he just
just went right through it and picked
his [__] up and was like I'm not going
to [__] indulge myself in that and I
respected that a lot and I would say the
second time is when maybe 9 10 months in
the relationship and I felt like I
wonder if he's ever going to like let me
in and we were at your one of your old
gyms and somebody was saying something
and then you looked to me and you said
well I'd really like your opinion and I
was like and in that moment I was like I
think he's making an effort to be more
collaborative and then he did and then
you like fat like very quickly
accelerated in terms of like your team
work no I respected your opinion if
there was ever something that we built a
relationship on the Bedrock has been
respect not love I think feeling in love
can come and go but at least for me
respect is more unchanging well yeah I
think all feelings are fleeting and
respect is like when I look on paper at
this person and their character and I
admire this person's character there are
going to be moments when people are in a
relationship or they're like [__] this
person you [__] so annoying whatever
everyone has those moments everyone has
those thoughts but when someone has like
really outstanding character and they're
a respectable person it's much easier in
this moment to be like I'm proud to be
married to this person and you know
you're not going to be feeling super
romantic most of your life like you're
going to be you know working at your job
you're going to be with friends you're
going to be out you're going to be
running errands you're going to be
stressed you're going to be dealing with
life [__] you're be with family you're
going to have kids like all these things
and so it's like in all of those moments
outside of like the fairy tale 60
Minutes every two weeks you get like how
do you feel about that person do you
ever have communication issues if not
what do you do to communicate so well oo
little assumption there if yes how do
you resolve them I think that we're
fairly good at recognizing when we're
not communicating well and we usually
try a different method of communicating
we step away for a second often times we
step away and then we write to each
other yep that's probably the biggest
go-to y because it gives us time to look
at our thoughts before we say them to
each other number one hack we text when
we're angry which is actually like seems
like opposite no it's not yeah that's
not how it is we're not like Angry
texting each other no it's like let me
clearly think out what I'm trying to say
and then I say it and then I like reread
it and I read hers I'm like okay she's
saying this you know and we just it
creates more space between the
communication so you can think about
your response and so for us I think it's
just decreased the emotionality that we
resolve things with I do think that one
of the keys besides the text thing is
that we we physically change
environments so it's like if you're a
tiff in the kitchen if she goes to the
living room and I go to my office and we
text it's like we both physically
changed environments we kind of left the
scene it just diffuses a lot I would
also say that you know we are busy and
so often times we need to go do
something and then we just come back to
it later and half the time we're like
yeah let's just [__] forget about it
like we're like it's not even like we
were just both whatever in the moment it
doesn't matter you were tired I was
hungry yeah and I think one thing that
we do well is we're willing to just like
let [__] go what are the non-negotiables
in your relationship if any that's a
good question yeah it's funny cuz I
think we talked about them more around
when we got married and now they're just
facts agreements agreements yeah
actually they were the negotiables they
were like what are the things that we
both mutually agree to and if we want to
change change one of these agreements we
both need to agree on it otherwise we
stick with what our commitment was this
will be quote unhealthy in the marriage
world but um I actually told Lila I was
like the business comes before our
marriage that was the first three years
of our marriage I know if I would say
that's a great advice for many no I'm
I'm just being I'm being candid yeah
yeah so people get divorced because of
money issues the business makes money
and feeds us so feed the business the
business will feed us and that was kind
of my reasoning then we were both
miserable at like threeyear point and L
and I sat on the bench one day
outside of our house and we were like I
don't like this and she was like I don't
like this either and we were both like I
wouldn't want to continue this way and
she I know going into that conversation
was afraid like well what if Alex just
like this is what he likes and this is
what he thinks normal and honestly if I
had said like I love this this is great
I think Lea would have been like this
doesn't work for me and then that would
have been it and the F if it had been
the same way with Ila I probably would
have been like it won't work for me and
so you know we tweaked the how how we
were going to work and so we said well
if we're miserable we won't stick with
the business so we were like let's make
our marriage first and if we're happy
then the business will win or not but at
least we won't be miserable and so when
we flipped it it actually tremendously
improved Our Lives I think we like I I
joked about it I was like I think we 3x
our marriage this year when we made that
change and she was like only an
entrepreneur would say that but yeah we
definitely tripled that year when we got
married we both looked at like the
highest success marriages are people who
have low expectations and high
commitment I'm going to expect that you
are going to not change and not only
that you might get worse and right and
I'm still committing to this provided
you you know don't change your values
and what you want to do things like that
like the big the big core things in
order to have a relationship where two
autonomous people can be together you
have to give each other that space to
just be experiment do what you want to
do find yourself at times change adjust
you know what I mean not freaking out
about things not being to your
expectations or to your desires it just
lowers the pressure in conversations
like the reason a lot of people split up
during like engagements is because
whenever you have conversations you're
like wait you didn't pick up your socks
does that mean that you're never going
to pick up your socks for the rest of my
life and for the rest of my life I'm
going to see socks on the floor like
they just catastrophize and so I think
just being like huh I don't like this
okay we're busy right now when we have
time I'll bring it up like it's not
going to end anything and if I forget by
the next time we talk then it's probably
not that big of a deal yeah and the flip
side is if everything is super so easy
like you just like let everything roll
off it's like usually just not
confronting [__] cuz no one no two
people are perfect together like there's
just always like there people you have
tons of different things and
Communications and things like that we
both know that both of us have these
things that are were huge strengths for
us and so then we each get to deal with
each other's like downsides of those
strengths you know which you know one
for me is like super high activity high
output driven can get a [__] ton of [__]
done I also care so much about so many
things that I I tend to stress more over
stuff yeah and I'm super super
distracted for the most part I can seem
aloof and disinterested in a lot of
small stuff which I think a different a
different spouse might interpret that as
Alex doesn't care about me I think Lea's
just never done that it's just been like
oh Alex just doesn't care about any of
this stuff and that's not a reflection
of his care for me it's just he just
doesn't care he doesn't it's not even he
doesn't care he just doesn't think about
I always appreciate it was that L never
tried to change me I think we seek each
other's opinion on things because we
respect each other's opinion not because
we need the approval yeah here's one
that you'll love how do you decide what
to do when you wake up and start your
deck try to get like the most important
things done early I mean I usually work
on the exact same thing for a very long
time I spent a long time thinking about
what one thing I'm going to do and then
once I decide that that's the thing that
makes the most sense from the most
angles that'll give me the most leverage
then that's what I do and then that's
like my first six hours of every day and
I've been doing that that habit of like
the first six hours of every day is
dedicated to the thing that matters most
I've been doing for since I started
working so I mean like a decade plus
some people it's like late at night so I
think it really just depends on who you
are but for me I'm a first thing in the
morning guys could either of you have
achieved the success you have without
one another yeah I think we could have I
think it would have been harder and I
think it would have taken longer and
it's interesting cuz I think right now
if I knew what I know now I could redo
it and I think if you knew what you knew
now you could redo it but to know what
we know now I don't know how long it
would have taken me to realize how
important operations were culture people
I would like I don't know like it would
have been I was a hard cell seriously I
was a hard cell yeah like I was a hard
cell it it was very rare that I had
somebody that I respected so much and
who was so persistent for such a long
time and had so much evidence behind
them that eventually I realized that the
way that I saw business in the world was
not entirely true like there was more to
the picture and so I think like knowing
what I know now yes how would I have
known what I know now I don't know
finding the right business partner is
difficult and so to say that you'll have
the same amount of success I think at
some point yes and you will find
eventually a partner but like it is
that's one of the hardest things I mean
we see it in acquisition. comom when
people apply all the time like often
times the business business is not where
it could be because the partnership is
not right and that is just more often
than not you can count on one hand the
amount of good partners you have in your
life you look at Charlie Munger and
Warren Buffett like they found each
other and we're like great this works we
don't need anyone else we're just going
to keep doing this and so like could
Laya have found someone else absolutely
could I find someone like Laya
absolutely how long would have taken I
don't know could I do it on my own
absolutely not we had so much in common
that we were like I don't know if we
should date or be friends or whatever
but like let's are we related yeah are
we related you could be my sister what
is your version of quality time with
your partner as business owners what do
you do when your partner wants to work
and you want to spend time away from
work for a bit wondering because my
partner and I own companies and work a
lot of the time I think that something
that we've learned and I I at least I
can speak for myself I have learned is
that you can want something and also not
get it and that is okay and there are
many times in a relationship where maybe
I'm because we tend to trade off Seasons
where Alex has a really intense work
season next season's Lea's really
intense work season so we don't match up
much and so so I might want to go do
something with Alex for the entire day
and also realize that I'm not going to
get what I want and I've I've recognized
with myself like in my young 20s like
wanting something and being mad that you
can't have it is a very childlike stance
to take but we're adults so I can want
that and accept that I'm not going to
get it and do something else instead if
there's a season where I have a day
that's free and Alex doesn't I go do
other things I make plans for myself I
entertain myself I can still do things I
like doing even though I prefer to do
them with him I can accept that he's not
in that season and the last thing I ever
want to do is deter him from his goals
and the things that make him happy and
fulfilled at the end of the day and so I
think it's understanding that you can
want something and not get it and it's
not a problem because there are many
seasons where that's just life I want to
emphasize lela's point which is that
because we work in the same business we
are almost always in a different season
now sometimes we're both in a busy
season but we're almost always one of us
is and so I think we've just grown
accustomed to the fact and we've shifted
our expectations around what the other
person must or should do in our
relationship in order to be satisfied
desire comes from a place of lack and so
when you don't always get to see your
spouse when you want to or get to spend
time with them when you want to when you
do it feels it's that much more fun it's
that much more exciting it's that much
more that you cherish it and I know for
us as we've gotten bigger goals and we
have more Demand on both of our plates
and we're probably both in a really busy
season right now the time that we do get
together like even this last weekend we
spent like an together and it was like
just chilling together doing nothing it
was like the highlight of my whole week
and it felt better than it may have if
that were like an everyday thing cuz
then You' probably just get sick of each
other I think it was Esther Perell wrote
meeting in captivity which Lea read the
book and then just told me what was in
it but she said she said that you need
to create space to be missed and I just
love that B Nation what's up you guys
are amazing we are Beyond grateful we
don't feel like we deserve it but we are
appreciative of all the support you guys
have had over the last year and uh we
can't wait to spend the next year with
you keeping one of zero 2024